hey folks
welcome back to the dark horse podcast
live stream
q a with more cat bell as requested
isn't that right
fairfax certainly is
all right here we go we are going to
start with two questions from last
episode
and uh then move on to the ones from
last hour so my last episode i meant the
one on july 28th
with the use of powerful lasers in riots
and protests has any concern been raised
in regards to injury to others beyond
the federal agents
this was interesting cause i just i i at
least have not heard
that raised as an issue yeah uh it is an
issue though
it is an issue but i haven't heard
anyone talk about it yeah lasers are uh
available now to the public that are so
powerful that you can actually do
significant
damage to people you can disrupt
aviation drones and actually commercial
aviation also
there are like some instances of people
shining lasers into the cockpits of
planes going overhead and things like
that that's been true for a while
yes that's yeah for a number of years i
don't know that the lasers have gotten
much more powerful in the last few years
but
but anyway there are real dangers here
and the fact is this is
a model for a lot of things which is we
are becoming
um incapable of dealing with
the weapons that are now available at
trivial expense so you're putting you're
putting these things in the hands of
people who
um are not prepared to deal with the
responsibility of it so
uh it's a little hard to say i have not
heard anybody discuss it beyond the
federal agents but obviously
you can reach an arbitrarily long
distance with these things and
um people will do it to the extent that
they identify targets beyond federal
agents
it's only a matter of time absolutely
okay so
uh the second question from
the live stream that we did a few days
ago uh and then we'll get to today's
questions
the ghost of live stream passed the
ghost the ghost of livestreams
pass exactly i will say that the
questions that came in today which i
only had time to
you know briefly look at insert are
amazing it's really good today and
are there any stumpers uh probably like
i actually am yes
i expect so uh what potential does
confirmation bias have in causing
science to go down the wrong path
and if something that's foundational is
found to be incorrect
how quickly can any given field reliably
course correct
great question yeah i thought so too uh
so i would say we have a built-in
problem which is that we have plugged
markets into
our thinking and sense making apparatus
and they are incompatible and so what we
have is a system
in which we basically award
the right to fund progress to whatever
school of thought we declare to be the
most
effective at any given moment and what
this means is that when a school of
thought
is on the rise it has the ability to
kill off its
competitors when it eventually runs into
extreme diminishing returns
there's nobody who left who knows how to
think any other way
this is an obvious thing that's
correctable yeah
the solution is completely clear but
we see field after field getting stuck
as a result of exactly this kind of
um broken modality so kind of sorry how
quickly can they recover
depends how long they've been going in
the same direction
and i think the problem is ultimately
the pattern we see
is well i mean we see it manifest in a
number of things i think it's
planck who uh said
science progresses funeral by funeral
and then
others have pointed out that it is very
frequently outsiders to a field
that um set new progress in motion
because the people inside the field
can't figure out what's gone wrong
they're too steeped in the
incorrect school of thought and
outsiders can come
you know we often think of that in terms
of
outsiders who are already expert in
something right like
um external people who are the peers
otherwise in terms of sort of rank and
society uh
but it's also of course what what the
youth do it's what it's what the people
up and coming in and discipline can do
when they when they are new to a field
they start looking around and go well
i'm gonna poke at that because that
doesn't seem to make sense and this this
reminds me of
uh the analogy that you told me a long
time ago about your experience
in high school when you were fencing uh
do you want to
and it's it's an observation that's been
made by other people for their context
but this is something you actually
experience
so i had the uh the good fortune of
being
a absolutely novice fencer
in a fencing program that had
a guy headed for the olympics
so he was an excellent fencer and the
thing is his excellent fencing
left an opening for you if you didn't
know what you were doing because the
point is
good fencers they narrow down to those
things that actually
make sense and so two well-matched
fencers
um you know have one kind of battle but
if you're just completely arbitrary
because you're new to it you don't know
what doesn't ultimately make sense you
don't win against a really good fencer
but you do score the occasional point
yeah um so anyway a newbie is
effectively a generalist an unwitting
generalist
to the specialist and this is part of
also the argument for mma
over very highly constrained martial
arts yeah
yeah um and i think it's really an
argument for a lot of things that
have grasped the public imagination of
late like
i must tell you i have very little
patience
for olympic gymnastics and now that i
have access to all sorts of interesting
parkour to look at
you know it's yep much harder to compare
to parkour performances because they
don't take place
against the same obstacles um but if
you're if you're ready to surrender i
mean
if what you're trying to do is judge who
is better it's
it's tougher to control because of what
it is right yeah and so you know i
i find the olympic skating and
gymnastics and all this kind of
mysterious because
people sit there watching something that
if they didn't have the commentary of
the judges they wouldn't know what the
best performance was
like you could spot an obvious error but
you don't really know what the high
quality performance was whereas
you do know if you're impressed at you
know somebody running up a wall and
doing a backflip
exactly um but you know the wall may not
be consistent right
one wall is not like another depending
upon what how slippery it is for example
um thus introducing into common pilots
it's like comparing walls to walls
wow i'm wondering if that's really going
to catch on without it
i hope not yeah that was that was brett
weinstein yes
because they're 20 20. it wasn't
okay okay um first question
for from this uh this previous live
stream
thank you for the incredibly generous
donation from matt
the psychedelic society of san francisco
is holding bypoc that's
um god was bypass stanford i know what
people of color stands for uh
bi it stand for biracial and indigenous
maybe
biracial i probably had this wrong i'm
gonna go with
biracials actually look it up indigenous
people of color
um i'm gonna start over the psychedelic
society of san francisco is holding
bypoc
and theogen integration circles you
mentioned people playing with dangerous
ideologies due to the accidental
consumption of air got fungus
and now seems people are intentionally
consuming entheogens and exploring these
ideologies in depth
any thoughts on this
black indigenous um i would say
this could be very hopeful if you had
something like
a decent guide but if you have
psychotics
can we get chloe to lead these just
anybody
just i mean yes chloe would be you know
the gold standard but you just need
somebody sane
right anybody's saying can could could
contribute something but
you can't put psychotics in charge of
guiding other people
through some trip or it's going to
just amplify the nonsense so i guess
look i mean yeah i mean god that just it
sounds if this is being led by the
standard sort of equity and diversion uh
equity and diversity crew
i think they're going to prompt a lot of
bad trips i mean that's just that's
that's not going to be a space in which
people
actually feel like they can let their
brain their brains
wander and and actually explore
all the different sensory and physical
stuff that's coming at them yeah i don't
trust them
uh that doesn't mean i don't trust these
people i don't know who's going to be
doing
it but i wouldn't trust the psychedelic
society of san francisco is i think
uh a long-standing and interesting
society
so it does dovetail with another point
that i used to make frequently which was
that there is
actually something tremendously
disturbing
about the fact that in some parts of the
world
san francisco being primary among them
and theogens are quasi-legal
and in other parts of the world like i
mean decriminalized not
is that what you mean but my basic point
is look if the silicon valley crowd
has access to mushrooms or ayahuasca or
whatever
that's an advantage that is being
preserved
by the fact that those very same things
might be prosecuted in a different
neighborhood
that's that's a privilege you know it's
easy to talk about uh
crack versus powder cocaine being uh
being effectively having racially
racially um specific profile
um what sentencing penalties right uh
but this
idea that this basic side to them right
that's like that's that's just
nasty but obvious but this sort of uh
actually
do you even have access to this kind of
thing you and also like just like i said
like that's going to prompt a bunch of
bad trips
to really to unless you're talking about
micro dosing you need
some serious time and space and the
ability to have some control over your
surroundings
to get anywhere close to guaranteeing
that you're not going to have a really
terrible time on it
yeah but i mean beyond terrible time the
problem is that this is a
mind opening drug and
because of that it can be open for
better or for worse
and what i would say is
i do think everybody needs equal access
which means they need to be
decriminalized to the same extent
everywhere
and frankly we're seeing a mind-numbing
lack of creativity about
social problems manifest in this
movement so could they use some
shamanistic exploration
sure but it can't be just a
reinforcement of the wrong ideas that we
are all now being force-fed that will be
disastrous
no i mean we've talked i specifically
have talked a lot about how i think that
most of these people haven't been
anywhere they haven't traveled they
haven't actually explored the world
well that extends to metaphorical as
well you know they need to open their
doors of perception somehow
and perhaps they can do it within their
own brains perhaps they can do it by
traveling the world
perhaps they could do it both ways but
absent any
such expansion of their very narrow
model of
what's right and what's okay they're
only going to get more ideological
yep now there is um
one thing again i i think the danger of
botching this in the current environment
is great but um
there's one thing that entheogens will
teach you that i think
is actually a vital lesson to getting
past this
this uh this woke nonsense which is
that your perception can absolutely lie
to you
right so you know good advice for people
experimenting with entheogens
who don't have prior experience is
you probably want to stay away from the
mirror
and you want to stay away from the phone
and that's because
it can be very unsettling an encounter
on the phone you're liable to do
harm if the person on the other end
doesn't know what you're
up to and have experienced themself
somebody who
did could handle it but you're liable
not to be able to navigate a phone call
and the mirror you know watching you
know your face melt
right that's not such an easy thing to
handle
away from the rest of you right exactly
on the other hand
wow how useful is it to have evidence
my what i think is my eyes
just lied to me because i know that
didn't happen right i can verify that
the skin is still on my face
therefore my eyes are not as reliable as
i interpret them to be under normal
circumstances
so what you're saying is basically it
can be used as a skepticism enhancer
if you're paying attention it will cause
you
to understand that your your perceptions
can be
anything up through an outright lie and
one that is not detectable on visual
grounds
and so um to the extent that we are
facing something that seems an awful lot
like psychosis getting people to say
you know am i having a psychotic break
that would be a step in the right
direction because
you might be having something that's a
lot like one yeah very good
you both are a sanctuary in a sea of
madness supposedly
99 of all species that ever lived are
extinct does this imply that most
species are dead ends
like the dodo or that we inflate the
statistic by including all ancestral
species of descendant species
both both the latter is trivial i think
the latter is trivial but it's true and
it's worth you know it's it's worth
noting that apparently given what i
revealed last hour you know many
biologists don't seem to understand
what the fact that we can't decide in a
single species concepts means
like that the the the fact that
the paleontological species concept
which names species
in uh within lineage different names
so we are given just take the example
that most people will be familiar with
humans
right we have several australopithecus
species and then several homo species
um some of which are slight branches off
of our lineage but many of which are
within
our direct lineage and they all have
different names and
that is a way for paleontologists um
to to talk to each other just to just to
know what they're talking about
and it doesn't pretend that those that
you know one didn't become the next
but it's very confusing especially when
um you know most of us
most non-biologists and in fact most
biologists just have implicit in their
brains
what's called the biological species
concept which is that if it can
you know if two animals can reproduce
and make viable offspring then it's a
species and if they can't then it's a
different species
and that's you know that's one of gosh
hundreds of species concepts and none
will
apply to all but this this
paleontological species concept does
contribute
slightly to the idea that some species
um are extinct now just because they've
been replaced by new ones with a
different name which isn't which isn't a
good definition of species well
it's it worse worse than the problem
with species is the uh
implication of extinction because to
evolve into something different is
not at all extinct exactly um yes but
in any case here's the thing so i would
say first of all if you got rid of that
ambiguity you would still have the same
overwhelming pattern and yes it does
mean that the majority of species are
dead ends which does not mean as much as
we think because
if so this goes into what i've called
explorer modes and i've taken no end of
crap
about which is fine because i will turn
out to be right in the end
but um the thing is if you imagine that
a clade
that is to say a cluster of closely
related critters
is actually exploring the various
possible ways to be
and that one of those explorations
actually results in the discovery of
something new
that is not a failure of the clade even
though the clade may get edited down to
a tiny fraction of the various
experiments
so it would be great if we had visuals
here but so you had species a
and it radiated into b and c and b and c
radiated into d and e and f and g and
all of this and you had species b
through z all of which were uh
were descendants of species a if
species b say ends up going on
and and its descendants do but
everything on the other half of the tree
goes extinct
uh that still leaves half of the
representatives
of of the original most recent common
ancestor of those species
um with representation in the world
right and yeah
the thing that we have said probably
sometimes with an actual tree
doing it with the hands is not good we
have a vermilion yes we do
and we have uh succulents from someone
who sent them to us who grows them from
seeds in arizona thank you um but
the uh the question is how do you get
into the future
not what you get into the future as
we're very focused on what you are
yeah but selection isn't and so here's
the final
cherry on top of this whole thing you
and
every other living entity that you can
point to
is the result of an unbroken
three and a half billion year stretch
of reproduction that never once
failed okay that is to say generation
after generation
for three and a half billion years your
ancestors never once
failed to make the jump even though
almost
everyone fails to make the jump within a
generation or two of existing
and you probably will as well but the
point is
selection is the result
of that weird comparison between the odd
creature
that never once in three and a half
billion years ever failed to reproduce
right and all of the other creatures
which were much closer to the normal
expectation which is to say failure
within a few generations
so that fact of being in the camp that
never once failed
is selection if you squint at it just
right and it explains
why this is such a powerful process what
does it say
to be in the tiny group of never failed
rather than the massive group of faileds
as normal
right it's it means you got all of the
stuff that works and even that's not
good enough to get you
three more generations forward in all
probability so anyway
it's a very interesting odd landscape
but
well worth considering yeah tremendously
fun to play around in
this is just a recommendation i don't
recognize it but i'll
read the comment regarding psychopathy
and politics
have you read political ponerology
the original manuscript went into the
furnace minutes before a secret police
raid in communist poland
sounds fascinating and neither of us are
familiar with it presumably a copy
was preserved yeah i know it's all up
here
i'm interested to read this yeah
and the next one is also a comment i
just listened to the billie holiday
just listened to billie holiday singing
god bless the child who's got his own
game theory 101. yeah be easier if it
was
god blessed the child that got his own
or who's got his arm isn't i mean it's
not the implication of the song
well it could be taken yeah as the
matthew effect
in other words the child that that has
got his own
is going to be blessed by god going
forward which is also
likely true yeah but anyway interesting
question i would have to go back and
listen to the lyrics specifically
but my guess is um
it is uh it is the
latter interpretation and not the former
okay
the dismissal of racism as evil seems
like a missed opportunity to discuss the
recognition of differences both
historically and presently
how would you teach kids this awareness
of differences with an evolutionary
framing
i mean we did this is exactly what we
did in our classes we did not pretend
that these things didn't exist we didn't
pretend that the histories were other
than they were
and everybody brought whatever
experiences in history they had with
them
we discussed them openly and you know
too little is made of the covenants both
formal and informal that we had in our
classes so one of the
interesting things so i mean that word
needs defining that a lot of what
happened at evergreen was in religious
language which is
maybe telling yeah but we were required
to have formal covenants
uh with our students um that we wrote
and uh
that established what their obligations
to us were what our obligations to them
were
what to do in case of grievance etc and
then they had to
sign them or you know implicitly agree
to them if they stayed in the program
and they could this was required by
evergreen it was required by evergreen
for every program
most of the ones that i saw and every
time you taught with somebody who
uh at any time you talked with somebody
you had to
co-fashion a covenant so you got to see
the covenants that they typically use
they saw yours and you combined them
and everyone that i saw short of hours
i thought read like an end user
license agreement that these things just
became
uninteresting and people signed them not
understanding
what the purpose was or anything it was
bureaucratic is there was there was
there was such an opportunity there and
most people didn't take it right but we
did we took our covenant seriously and
in fact my covenant began to have a
warning on it that said
this is not an end user license
agreement yeah you did actually
explicitly put that in there and use
your license agreement is designed for
you not to read it
and to sign away your rights this is
designed for you specifically to read it
and understand
what situation you're walking into and
what rights you have that you may not
know
right but my point was in those
documents
we included stuff about how specifically
you were to walk something back
if you screwed up if you offended
somebody it wasn't going to be
nobody was going to be canceled but you
had the right to
um uh to say i didn't mean
what it sounded like i meant oh cat has
now deleted something
kitty um thank you but
uh you had the right to take it back to
apologize
oh you can't do this no
dude that's just wrong um
not okay but anyway uh the
the mechanisms for dealing with offense
without causing a catastrophe were built
into the structures that we were using
as you know that's the point
and um were you going to say anything
specific about
awareness of differences i mean i guess
we did that in the classroom
rather than in the covenant such that
um you know i in in some of my types of
programs
i would say in the preamble basically
both of us had so many
students who wanted to get into the
programs that we were trying to scare
people away so that we
were left with the ones who were just
trying to scare the people away who were
most likely to yeah we were trying to
disrupt we wanted the most anti-fragile
students the ones who
may maybe they had no background at all
even in an upper division science
program that was totally fine
but if they were going to require a
certain kind of uh
thing that they'd always had before in
school or i require that they
had their hands held while if their if
their feelings were hurt then
um that was that was much tougher to
have in the classroom
right um so i would say i guess it was
in my animal behavior programs uh which
some version of which we then taught
together in our final study abroad
program
um we're going to be talking about
difficult things like the evolutionary
underpinnings of genocide and
rape and we're not going to justify any
of that
but if even getting near those topics is
going to make you so uncomfortable that
you can't conceive of a scientific
discussion on such topics you should
probably find someplace else to go
and you know to their credit i had some
students who were like oh that is going
to make me nervous but i've got to stick
around and see what that looks like
yep and that those were often the most
the bravest
ultimately and the ones who learned the
most so i have a uh
an anecdote i'm be very careful um
to protect the young woman in question
but yeah i had a student
in my first or second year teaching
who um had been
violently attacked on a study abroad
program attacked by locals not people on
the trip
she had been raped and i warned her
about the
topics in the class and very much to her
credit
her sense was no i i have to i have to
hear what you have to say
and then she actually did a project and
wrote a paper on the exact topic of the
evolutionary
meaning of rape which is not an easy
topic for any of us to deal with
and i was just so deeply impressed with
her courage and her ability to actually
carry it off to understand and you know
it was clearly something she needed to
do to heal but
it wasn't you know she didn't tell
herself some story that she wanted to
hear
she confronted it full strength and
anyway
and did you do you think that it was
healing for her i have no question about
it
no question about it in fact we talked
about it you know that's another thing
that evergreen did well
was uh we spent a lot of time with
students one-on-one in small groups
around campfires at the end of the
program uh you sit down with them and
you have a conversation
one-on-one yeah um so i know exactly
what she thought
and uh it was it was
exactly what you would have hoped and it
is exactly the opposite message of this
sort of
trigger warning safe space uh you know
keep every wound open because it's your
most valuable feature
it was the opposite of that and uh
anyway so
with with your program and by
introducing her to
what you taught her and by giving her
forum to write that you allowed her to
move her wound into becoming a scar scar
yeah and i
uh i have no doubt that it was a
major contributor to her quality of life
going forward anyway if she's out there
she knows who she is
uh i admire you and i'm thinking of you
that's amazing
seen on a sign in front of a church in
new hampshire denial
feeds racism i am looking for a concise
rebuttal
to this it seems like a kind of kafka
trap
it does seem like african traffic it
seems very much like a kafka trap and
that's the thing about kafka traps is
they defy rebuttal that is exactly what
they do that is the only thing that they
do
well in this case there is
certainly a true interpretation of that
statement
okay so a concise rebuttal may involve
first steel manning
right okay are there well in the case
that there is racism
denial of it does preserve it right sure
collective denial of it even worse
um that however does not it needs it
needs a preamble where racism exists
denial makes it stronger right but the
denial that there is racism somewhere
does not imply that it exists which is
exactly
what happened at evergreen and is now
happening in public which is not to say
that there is no racism but you know the
allegation that there is white supremacy
rampant at evergreen no
not white supremacy right you could have
ignorance
but no this was a community that was
very eager to make sure that these
properties didn't exist there so
it doesn't mean it wasn't inept but
white supremacy is the wrong diagnosis
but i think i mean i think you actually
came up with the answer here or we did
together
looking for a concise rebuttal to this
well
where racism exists denial makes it
stronger
but denying that racism exists does not
prove the existence of racism
nor is it racism as we were that's
that's also true there's a lot more that
you can be said but in terms of a
concise
like two sentence like deal with that
now okay you gave me three words
you sign on a church or whatever it was
um i'm gonna give you two sentences and
make sure he's gonna squeak um and
see you know see what happens next well
i don't know why you're so eager
to make this concise response short i
just seems like we could
attack stuff onto it and certainly
couldn't really turn it into something
yes here we see you know one of one of
the other things about evergreen was we
had like
three hour blocks to do lectures in and
they were meandering
and they they were wonderful you know
that sounds awful if you've been in
almost any lecture how can you expect
people to keep their butts on seats for
that long it's terrible
but these were very much back and forth
interactive
explorations and so we're used to having
rather a lot more time
yes than we can here and also having
actual people to interact with besides
ourselves
okay next question thank you for hours
of incredibly valuable
discussion have you considered talking
to preet bharara
i would love to hear a conversation
between you two keep up the good work
psm and it dev with 10 years of
experience are you going to help if
needed do you know who this is
i don't either so this is another uh one
i just don't even know who it is
um please comment on the involved
implications
for the industry of cia's project paper
clip
and its cover-up of nazi recruits
post-world war ii infiltration into key
positions
into the u.s and scientific the u.s
scientific and intelligence operations
in aerospace
pharma and media yeah um i don't know
what
industry i've seen yeah i don't i mean i
don't think that i do not call it
it's not project paper club it's
operation paperclip yes
which was about uh bringing um
uh germans who were
tainted by their connection to the nazis
into
american industry and other things just
post world war ii
yeah basically we uh we grabbed those
who were ideologically tainted and
perhaps were actually
uh bad in this regard and uh
made the uh made
american science stronger by virtue
having stolen their brains from germany
yeah and i remember from youth um a
tom lehrer song about werner von braun
that's right who uh had claimed
that once the rockets were up who cares
where they come down that's not my
department
said verner von braun but um but anyway
yeah so the evolved implications though
the evolved implica well the evolved
implications
are that there is murky game theory
under all of this stuff
and the question is do you
um are you going to banish the
conclusions
in neurobiology for example that were
discovered
as a result of people getting parts of
their head blown off
and us discovering therefore what
controlled what
just because people getting their heads
uh blown off is grotesque um
so anyway i don't know what there is to
say except that well one one thing that
might be
implied in the question which we would
just disagree with i'm not i'm not sure
it's in this question but one thing that
i see is a possible implication here is
that
um those uh nazi germans
who were pulled into u.s science and
therefore and thereafter became
uh part of u.s society and i don't know
actually but probably
intermarried and had kids here would
they be more likely to make nazis
not genetically there is no reason to
expect that you know nazism is
is genetic but culturally
would those ideas have potentially had
greater reach here because there were
actual people who
held under those beliefs in germany
maybe although i would expect that
uh being in the u.s among
lots of people who were so thrilled at
the end of the war
and the end of nazism uh would have
helped
uh tamp down those beliefs so i'm gonna
now i know what i think in response to
this question i'm not sure that that's
that's one read on this question i'm not
sure that's the intention let's say that
that's the reading okay here's what i
would say
there is um a great difference between
rehabilitating somebody who actually did
advance the ball of nazism because their
knowledge is valuable
right that is um
dangerous precisely because in bringing
whatever expertise they have you're also
dragging a broken
ideology that's manifestly dangerous on
the other hand
there's a question about how many people
were carried along inside of germany
in spite of their sense that this wasn't
right and so we faced the same thing
in this modern context where it's very
difficult to distinguish
between people who earnestly believe
this nonsense and people who claim to
believe it and then rationalize
themselves
into advancing it because in their
social milieu there's no other way to do
anything
and so i feel certain without knowing a
great deal about the particular
individuals involved in operation
paperclip
that it will have been a mixed bag we
will have done it in both cases and so
there will be cases in which you know
like conrad lorenz who we've
talked about here briefly who was a
member of the nazi party later went on
to regret it
um and did actually advance the ball
within evolutionary biology that seems
a case where we're perfectly justified
and accepting somebody who did wrong
things but
you know he wasn't a murderer he
understood the error of his ways
regretted them and then there will be
other cases in which
we have uh accepted somebody because
uh we allowed the value the utility of
what they knew
to outweigh the horror of what they
believed
and probably that's the line that one
should draw
okay we've got um 10 more questions that
are i think really good in this stream
alone
before we switch so let's try to get
through these
please comment on your belief in the
possibility of performing something
of performing something into being for
example
can certain behavior that is enacted
over and over create certain permanent
attitudinal or belief states
enactment leading to an empathic state
for instance
um i feel certain that if we chase this
down far enough we will know for sure
that it is possible yeah
um that uh
not i mean there are certain things that
can't be performed into being
right but um
but let's put it this way to the extent
that something is belief-based
you can start out not believing it and
espousing it
and then you can end up believing it and
so i think that's a demonstration of the
principle right yeah i guess i
feel like there's lots of easy examples
you know practice makes perfect is true
for many many things
and then there's some examples where you
know you can't or
it just won't be but i'm we're more
interested in all that middle ground
where some people would disbelieve it
and
and i think we would both tend to
be less skeptical than some as to its
possibility but i'd like
i'm not coming up right now with some of
those murky middle examples where there
might be real disagreement
um yeah i mean i guess maybe i'm not
sure
sure what the question means but it
seems to me that
um you can't do anything about
factual reality unless that the fact in
question is one of belief
but that belief can transform
a landscape and oh actually you know
what
here's the example
the rwandan genocide based on a conflict
between
hutus and tutsis and these two groups as
i understand it
were not real lineages
they were assigned based on phenotypic
characteristics which may or may not
have indicated something about lineage
but certainly did not do it in any
precise way
in other words people with certain
characteristics were assigned to
to hutu for example and there was no um
reality within the culture within like
myth or cultural belief in advance of
the
assigning i believe that is correct that
this was actually
in some sense it was top down a top down
you've got a star and you don't it was
star-bellied sneetches
uh and it resulted obviously
in a political murder and then a
genocide
um so i wonder if that's not the
ultimate example of it well
yeah amazing unity 2020 question
family member asked how the organization
will decide that x and y are center
right and center left
i had a response but like your input
thanks um
i think we're going to have to just do
it and i think in most cases
it doesn't it's not controversial i did
have
a back channel conversation with
somebody who
we were and are looking at as somebody
who could potentially inhabit one of
those spaces
and i asked him where he would place
himself
and we had a very good discussion based
on it and it turned out um
it wasn't simple in his case um that
there were actually arguments to be made
both ways
but that um
probably from the perspective of most
voters he would be
right of center and so anyway
if you come down to something that is uh
divided such that is very near
the middle it actually matters less um
but in this case
uh but the but the optics are such that
um
you want to have someone who appears to
be more in the blue side and someone
else who appears to be more on the right
side
given the whole premise of unity 2020.
well i don't think it's so much a
question of optics i think it's a
question of assurance
that the thing that causes people to
accept that some plan like this might
work
is the idea that it doesn't run the risk
that their values will not be
represented in the room
where decisions are made so if the rumor
decisions are made as the white house
and it's a team that's making those
decisions
what i want to know as a voter is is
there somebody in that room
who gets what motivates me right because
then i know i'm not going to be
shut out of the discussion which is now
the common experience
so somebody who's very much in the
center
is hearing people either side and so
your
values are still understood in the room
so i think it's protection enough
yeah next question seems our culture has
messed up sexuality so
badly that it's hard to know where to
begin how should children be educated
about it
earlier later both
where to begin with sexuality look it's
not a new answer but dinner
dinner
you gave me that look it wasn't bedroom
eyes either
um yeah so
what i was going to say uh we have we've
written a fair bit in
our in our book which will be out next
year about um
how we might fix some of the ways that
culture our modern culture is
screwed up our understanding of sex and
gender and sexuality but we specifically
didn't and also about childhood
um but we have not explicitly talked
about how children should be educated
about it
uh and i don't have a i don't have a
ready a ready answer on this i think
um we
we talked with our children early about
almost
everything without being graphic about
anything
and almost i think everything that i've
heard either of them
say about what they heard in school has
been
nonsense yeah and you know
i would have expected from i don't even
know that i remember any sex ed in
school but
my sort of model of what sex ed is is
it's banal and uninteresting and just
you know
leaves you not really knowing anything
except a few things about the mechanics
and um instead what we've heard from
our kids in late elementary and middle
school which they're now beyond
uh was actually just wrong just wrong
stuff uh in including you know
including the chromosomes exist on a
continuum and such
um so i would say a couple things one
based on
uh what we've seen you have to alert
them
to the fact that they are going to hear
garbage and that they not only have
license to absent themselves from it
even if not vocally in other words they
may have to nod their heads and answer
the questions on an
exam in school as if x but that
it's your duty as a parent to alert them
that there is a bunch of
modern pseudo sophistication that they
will be
probably forced to pretend they agree
with
as children it cannot be expected that
they will fight that battle
at their place it is potentially
dangerous
in a family context to absent yourself
from this
nonsense because it will
expose you to accusations of bigotry and
worse
but you don't really have any choice
because you're dealing with one of the
central
birthrights that we have right which is
a healthy
sexuality and just the same way a
molester interrupts
healthy sexuality and has no right to do
so your school doesn't have any right
to disrupt your child's understanding of
what's going on with them
no matter what its objectives are so
you have to prepare them for the lies
you have to tell them
the truth as best you understand it um
you know give them a sense that
sexuality is a
a strange and interesting landscape in
which
uh things are not narrow and simple it's
not fairy tale stuff
so uh they shouldn't feel that they are
off just because
it is not something anybody's explained
to them
in a way that leads them to anticipate
it correctly but in some sense your job
as a parent
is to fight the nonsense wherever it
comes from
even when it's the state maybe
especially when it's the state
oh and the final thing is maybe
top of the list is you should give your
kids
a really healthy warning about
pornography
because the following fact is true
historically speaking
people have in general learned about sex
by observing it right because people
lived in
very close quarters and so it was
observable
children pretended to be asleep when
their parents had sex and they learned
what sex was
actually like which means that
they are sensitive to messages about
what sex is like and because pornography
is
motivated by market forces it is
therefore
inherently prone to extremes
why because you've got a bunch of
pornographers trying to get your money
and the only way to get your money is to
stand out
so extreme sex is the norm in porn
which then causes a young mind that
can't calibrate this stuff
to think that the extreme stuff is the
norm
and then it craves that thing so what i
would say
is you don't need to be detailed and
graphic about it with your kids but you
do need to say look
there are certain things out there that
are poison
and porn though it may appeal to you
is poison because it is motivated by
people who are interested in getting you
to pay right it will misinform your
sexual mind and you should stay away
from it which is not
a critique of sexual content um
erotica is a very different phenomenon
but anyway i would say a good healthy
warning about porn
is a requirement in order for your kids
to
avoid the pernicious market-based
garbage
yeah there are places that the market
doesn't belong humor
science this sports
sex courts um i will say that we we talk
a little bit about that in the book
and i speak to that issue specifically
in a um
article coming up in nautilus as well um
but it's not
about um neither in the book nor in my
article do we
is it about how to talk to children
about it um
but but yes speaking very clearly and
explicitly about the dangers of
of porn once they're old enough to
potentially be running into it which
you know may be very very early at this
point
four tech ceos were grilled by congress
on wednesday
do you have any thoughts negative
impacts range from political
manipulation
media and corporate are more aggressive
millennials living life through sound
bites
mental health issues accelerated is
break up the right solution
so i would i knew this happened but i
have not um i have not seen the
testimony so i would need to know more
but
um before i really weighed in on whether
or not breakup
uh was the right solution breakup might
be part of it but it's not the whole
thing
certainly it's not the whole thing the
monopolistic power is a problem because
what it does
is it means that the dysfunction is
concentrated in these overwhelmingly
powerful
entities and if you broke them up it
would be divided up more finely and
you'd have more choice to go to places
that were less pernicious and all
yes um however i would say the real
point is that we do not have
an understanding of our own rights and
needs relative
to an online universe that the uh
legacy code from our constitution for
example
just simply does not prepare us for a
private public square with algorithms
running in the background that decide
whether or not you are to be
shadow banned or who knows what so what
we need
is an understanding of what the
obligations are for a healthy
conversation to take place online
and what the structures would need to be
in order to make sure that that
continues
david cho on rogan described living with
the hudson people in africa one of the
last hunter-gatherer groups
can you elaborate about the hadzas and
their culture
and i um i would maybe like to come back
to this
we've both um read a fair bit about them
but i don't
i can't do much on the topic yeah i can
do it off the top of my head they'll get
something wrong
exactly exactly yep a deer attacked
blm protesters in new jersey is there
biological evidence
to suggest that deer are racist how do
you recommend they check their privilege
and implicit bias
is this retaliation for the whiteness of
hunting
yes this is the one i was laughing at
earlier yes
no maybe definitely
and we should talk about that further in
it well i mean why do you think they
took that elk statue down in portland
i was just getting there so right but
yeah it's definitely the retaliation for
the whiteness of hunting
yeah um obviously all the first hunters
were not white
because all the first people were not
white and we were hunting
long before we were humans and uh
so uh boy i like the question
it's ridiculous it points out how
ridiculous things are
yeah what is the best way to start
learning evolutionary biology for a
newbie are there good books or online
courses lectures anything else you'd
suggest for me to get started
i think we listed some books a couple a
couple times ago
i have some dawkins books uh and
i don't i don't have a i you know we've
thought about doing an online course and
we
aren't at this point but yeah i mean at
some level
you can teach yourself and especially
with uh resources
you know we pointed out several dawkins
books that are
good the selfish gene ancestors tale
climbing improbable
yeah climbing mountains probably my top
three um but anyway if you can get that
under your belt
and then you know one of the things i
used to do in class
was we would take a natured documentary
often uh attenborough are the best they
have the fewest
errors in them evolutionarily he's quite
good on this front
but we would take one of the
documentaries
and we would go through it and anybody
in the room could shout pause
anytime they wanted and you know it
could take three days to get through one
of these things three weeks more like
yeah it could be it could be either but
the point is you would go through and
just extrapolate from what you were
hearing
first of all you would test it against
your model are they saying something
wrong because
you know that sounds unlikely um but
anyway you could do this and we would
have these great discussions about each
of the
segments and i see no reason that you
and a few friends
well it's tough though if you don't have
a fact check in the room
in the form of you or me or you know we
we did this with bob trivers
you know like it it's tough i imagine
that would be very tough to know
when you were going down some path that
didn't make sense if there's no one in
the room who knows any better than you
do yet
about um how you know what a falsifiable
prediction sounds like
well you need some grounding which is
why i suggested starting with those
books
but um i have the sense that it's a
little bit like
learning to play tennis by going out on
the court and volleying which is to say
you're not going to know that you have
it right and it's not to say that you
won't learn the occasional bad habit
but if you do it and you like it a
you're going to tune into evolutionary
stuff
and you will begin to get a sense for
yeah
it's it's tough though i mean the
attenborough documentaries are really
the only
ones like it is alarming how much
just bad thinking and untrue things are
in almost every nature documentary like
just put aside the fact that almost all
of the footage
uh is you know is of
extremely rare but true things and sort
of made to look like it's happening all
the time
or worst case scenario but are all too
common just fabricated just not what it
appears
but um even if the footage you're
looking at is real
if rare uh the the narrative that goes
over it in
almost every nature documentary out
there is often
so bad and they'll just slip in untrue
things with
with true things and bad thinking with
good thinking such that
you know i'm not i'm not surprised that
most people don't know how to do
the logic because this is you know
nature documentaries is what a lot of us
grow up on
and um if you've never had someone say
yes that doesn't make any sense
look at that um that does and this is
what i did this
very rarely but you did this a lot in
your classes and this is exactly what
you were doing as you were training
people's brains to start questioning
even those things when they're said in a
nice sonorous voice
um are actually not true yeah right um
yes so uh yeah
all of that i think if it can work it
won't be perfect
but uh it's a skill and it's it's
learnable
on your own to an extent yeah uh
okay two more questions here and then
we'll go to the next live stream
are you too familiar with the book why
fish don't exist by lulu miller
it traces the life of 19th early 20th
century biologist david star jordan and
explores some of the great mysteries of
life and meaning worth checking out
so i will say i have not read the book
but i listened to her
on i think it was radio lab and it drove
me
crazy she so clearly misunderstood
basic evolutionary principles like
you know so the very the title of the
book why fish don't exist she really
thinks that fish don't exist because
um we call things not fish that are fish
like the presence of the existence of
mammals suggests that fish don't
exist and so basically because we would
have to be fish then fish don't exist
yeah and you know that i i could see you
doing that in a way that was kind of
okay but she
it seemed super ideological and really
driven
to to much like so much critique of
evolution of biology is and she's not
you know she's
she's not she's not uber woke
uh it's not that kind of critique but
but at least in this interview
i was yelling at her while i was in the
car driving listening to this podcast
so the fact that someone who's listening
to us says oh actually this book makes
sense
you know it might be it might be worth
reading um and then
doing a book review uh well i must have
been listening to this this year
last and if she was interviewing about
it it's new it's a new book
it is possible that she's in fact
responding to
our insistence that we are fish and that
this is kind of a way of i know i don't
think so
no it's i mean it's it's not
i mean how long do it if the fact of
mammals means that fish don't exist
that's the that's an inversion of our
take on it which is that mammals are
fish yeah but that's not what this book
is
oh okay no and it's not um it's
there's no way it's a response to
anything going on in in our sphere
um but anyway it's you know it's sort of
a historical biography that
that bae may have more value than i
thought uh given this
given this recommendation but um what i
heard from the author did not lend
confidence
um one more question but also
do you want to say anything about this
the this person who
my colleague needs your help to stand up
to the sjws
i joined your patreon to join the google
hangout you want to say something
publicly to this person yeah somebody
has asked
they've joined patreon in order to get
in on the discussion
tomorrow morning and they may have
joined it too late to get the link
uh to the discussion but i will get them
the link and anybody who signs up late i
will get the link maybe i'll just resend
the link tonight to everybody who's
all the all the patreons on that level
yep all right
okay final question from this and then
we'll skip to the next one
does woke culture equal toxic femininity
the manipulative overuse of the victim
card
might be the same thing as a woman
trying to get out of its speeding ticket
emphases on safe spaces and language
policing
are the same thing as the archetypal
consuming overprotective mother
unless i'm not sure about that last one
um
but the but the framing i think is quite
interesting and it fits with
it being a female dominated movement and
it does not reflect the best of
of femaleness at all i think i think
that's the important thing
is that uh
toxic femininity is not synonymous with
femininity any more than toxic
masculinity is synonymous with
masculinity
and so which is exactly the point that i
made in my
essay of that name for colette yes so in
any case i do think that there might be
something to the idea that the
particular dysfunction we are seeing
leans more towards the
toxic feminine than the toxic masculine
but the toxic is the problem
yeah although i mean frankly the um
the people who are more prone to
violence it's sort of you know it's it's
we're now getting
you know maybe the stuff that happens in
the workplace is more toxic femininity
style
garbage and the place the violence in
the streets is more toxic masculinity
style garbage
and it's just it's toxic either way and
you know neither of us really love
this you know toxic x framing but um
you know men are more likely to use
physical force and women are more likely
to use
emotional coercion to get what they want
when they're aggrieved and
um you know not reflecting the best of
what they could be doing
yeah but even the violence here it is
masculine in a way
but the point is what is it pointed at
and how did it get pointed at that
in other words it's sort of a uh
decimate the inconvenient
right so anyway i
i'm unsure but there is something there
is something to this
all right where are the remaining okay
here we go
did you draw a line here zach yes
okay here we go
okay well we'll get through a few of
these from this hour
female here when i get sick my libido
skyrockets
this makes sense to me for males last
chance to spread seed but not in females
is my brain confused
or is there an evolutionary reason i
don't see
gosh i think it depends it really
depends on what kind of sick you are
yeah right like there's just there's a
lot of ways to be sick and if it's just
sick across the board then
that doesn't like there's no way to put
an evolutionary explanation
to that because um there are too many
different ways to be sick what that
means but
um you know if it you know if it's
if it's an sdi it could be the
the pathogen doing its bidding and
trying to get you to spread it
uh if it even if it's you know something
respiratory or gut it could be the
pathogen doing its bidding and trying to
get you to spread it
that's a fair point um yeah really
anything that is spread by close contact
but the question i have is is this a
common pattern
yeah i had never occurred to me i don't
experience it
never occurred to me i've never heard
anyone say it yeah um
but uh yeah beyond the is it is
this the pathogen doing its bidding um
i don't i agree with the person asking
the question
that a sort of a dandelion strategy
doesn't apply to
females it only applies to males yeah
dandelion strategy being upon being
picked spread your seed
you might have a last chance to to
reproduce after all
uh next one from the militant moderate
who supplied that uh
unity poem that i read on air a time or
two ago
he says seems i assume he seems my unity
poem was appreciated i also
specialize in writing song parodies can
you think of a song you'd like to hear
rewritten for the project
please not american pie it's overdone
also shout out to new
discourses yeah so new discourses is uh
james bogogian's i think it's just him
maybe it's peter too i think it's just
james
um james lindsay's uh project it's great
um yeah let us think on that
unless you have something i was hoping
it would come to me but i
i don't have it but i do have a feeling
that there's room for this oh absolutely
it could be great
it would be totally great zach would you
uh highlight that's it's number 46
in the um spreadsheet
primate sperm release through asphyxia
tissue mechanism or adaptation so
low-ranking males can impregnate females
before being strangled away from them by
dominant males
question mark how widespread is this in
the animal realm
um that's a plausible hypothesis i
couldn't make you or you could make
sense of what i read i couldn't make
sense of the words yep
yeah um the question is i think
motivated by
the fact of autoerotic asphyxiation
and what it means about primates and
that it probably does mean something
about
uh last-ditch efforts at reproduction
that
happened not unrelated to the first two
questions ago exactly
um so i would say you don't need to go
all the way
to its males uh ejaculating as they're
being
forced away from females that they're
copulating with although that obviously
makes sense um but basically the idea
that anything
that threatens the life of an individual
who is engaged in sex if that individual
is male
obviously there's an evolutionary win
if reproduction is successful so yep
basically you don't need you don't need
the scenario to be nearly as specific as
the one you're drawing though that one
works
good here we have a quote from jerry
garcia
constantly choosing the lesser of two
evils is still choosing evil didn't know
he had said that yeah that's rather
apropos with the
most recent unity 2020 animation the
most recent unity 2020 animation which
you can find as my most recent tweet
and you could retweet it yourself or
whatever you want to do but anyway it'd
be cool to spread it around
is elon musk deploying a similar
strategy to trump's in his efforts to
elevate discussion about the pyramids
boy musk is talking about the pyramids
what's he saying about the pyramids oh
did i catch a straight tweet in a couple
days did he allege that the pyramids
were
alien and original um
you know he's having around he's a
shaman he
he's going full shaman and sometimes
shamans are really wrong
yeah i'm wrong really wrong
right yeah there's a lot of i this is
news to me but
if that's what he's claiming i i wish i
i looked at it in passing because i i
think i took it to be
um fiction but
um you never know with him so i don't
think we can address the actual question
without knowing exactly what
he's done right yep now there was an
amazing
display at the university of michigan
museum
about the museum of zoology uh no it was
the ruthman museum
museum zoology so this is this is our
alma mater well it was the entire museum
had uh a display about how the pyramids
came to be
in spite of the various mysteries which
include the fact that there's no quarry
from which the stones could have been
taken
nor a plausible mechanism for their
transportation
and this display argued very
compellingly i thought
i mean very compellingly that this was
nile sediment that was
cast in place um which would seem
you know that's in my head and maybe
it's because i saw that display and
that's just what i understand it to be
yeah but so i don't know whether that
has become
uh the standard interpretation or that
interpretation has been falsified in
some way in which case i would want to
check whether the falsification was
right or whether
we have thrown out the right explanation
because it answered so many questions
yeah nile sediment cast in place right
yeah carry it up one bucket at a time
it's lighter too carried up without the
water
um i think it would have to have been oh
i know it wouldn't be lighter because it
would
although all the water would eventually
evaporate out once in this cast
yeah yeah what about the role of disgust
as a psychometric factor in conservatism
i heard this in a jbp lecture yeah i
think that um there are a number of
these
um sort of big five and other cycle
personality traits
that are traceable to people left of the
aisle versus right
and um disgust is a
i think just maybe a more frequent
emotion that is reported as being
experienced by
people who identify as conservatives i
don't know what more to say about that
nope yeah um favorite nature
documentaries question mark this came in
before we started talking about nature
documentaries yeah i think so basically
anything by attenborough um and there
are some other good ones out there but
attenborough has i don't know
how he came to but he just understands
more about
evolution that oh yeah than anyone else
who is doing these things and
and now has a team i don't he's probably
not doing them anymore he's still alive
but yes
but um he clearly has a team around him
and they consult with people who
actually know what
a compelling evolutionary story is and
whether that's
falsifiable and what isn't and uh they
don't tend
he doesn't you don't tend to see in
attenborough documentaries
uh truly bad evolutionary stories
yep by which i mean unfalsifiable
some id some id now kova tests are
performed outdoors
is it possible that swabbing your nose
while standing in the sun
could harm the test results yes yeah
absolutely i didn't i didn't know that
um
i didn't know that they were some of
them were being performed outdoors but
absolutely you would want to do it under
some sort of undercover protective yeah
thing
absolutely i mean even then it's so
sensitive to uv that bouncing around
yeah yeah we're gonna we'll talk more
about covid
next time but there's just there's so
much trouble with the tests
yep um
have you considered having a chat with
judy mkovitz given the parallels between
her story and your experience with my
telomeres
nope now we talked we talked about uh
the pandemic video back
i don't even know when it would have
been sometime in the tens um sometime
between episode 10 and
probably 16 uh and uh
and i don't know which one it was in but
go back there and
there's a lot of misinformation in it so
much so
that i just don't trust the source yep
uh let's do
three more
two more i can't there's a bunch
cat deserves more screen time that
doesn't count as one yes he does but
not if he's going to show his butt to
you guys that wasn't nice
okay two more here thoughts on the
novelty do you have thoughts on the
novelty of today's tech monopolies
versus possibly outdated antitrust
structures is hyperscalability a novelty
that could be mistaken for trust or
anti-competitive behavior of the past
so this presumably to this this
wednesday yeah
yeah there is clearly a parallel the
parallel is clearly limited
there's clearly upside you know we're in
a novel landscape and so
in some sense creating a monopoly can
create a de facto
standard where a standard may need to
exist so it's not like there isn't a
positive outgrowth but the hazard to us
is also so
clearly um massive
that you know we have to figure out how
to rescue the part
that is useful um from the part that is
devastating
one more question can you please speak
about blood types why do we have them
how did they evolve why would oh be more
resistant to covet 19
love the podcast thanks for all you do
from south carolina
you want to do two minutes on blood
types are you prepared to i mean we can
talk a little bit about how they work
yeah that's that's about all yeah i'm
struggling with my chair today
all right so your red blood cells have
so an antigen is a molecular
signature and your cells have antigens
sticking
off of them that is to say a
distribution of
positive and negative charges in space
that is
unique there are
two no three that uh
are found on the surface of human red
blood cells
one of them is called a one of them is
called b and the other one is called the
rh factor or rhesus factor
a and b exist at the same place
in the genome so that you can because
you have two chromosomes you can have
an a and the absence of
a code you can have a b in the absence
of a code
you can have an a and a b or you can
have both
absences which will give you an o blood
type
but basically the blood types are
described based on the presence of an
antigen
so if you have an a a b or an rh factor
that's a presence
and you get o when you have a total
absence of all of those
well no an absence of the a and b factor
and rh is categorized separately
and so these things create and where
where is rh
like where does it it's not it's somehow
in a different part of the genome is
that all
or does it is it affixed to a different
part of the cell as well nope i think
they're all over the surface and it's
just a different
uh locus okay so you can you can be you
can have the a antigen or the b antigen
or both of them or neither
and you can have the rh antigen or
neither yeah and if you have for
instance the b
antigen and not the rh your b negative
right that would be your blood type
positive and negative are about the rh
factor right
and so there's a
rule the presence of an antigen triggers
the immune system
the immune system is designed to
recognize that which is not self
so that is to say your immune system
will react to something as foreign
if you yourself don't make the antigen
in question so
if you have a b positive blood
you carry every antigen what that means
is you can take blood from
anybody because no matter what antigens
they have you will regard it as self
since you
produce all of those things if you have
o
negative blood then you're a universal
donor but you can only take blood from
another o negative person because
any antigen will trigger your immune
system to reject the blood
if you if you get a negative blood which
has only one antigen that you don't have
the a um your your body will say that's
not self
respond create antibodies to uh
to reject it literally fight the tissue
and kill it yeah
um which is very dangerous to have
happening in your bloodstream
um the rejection of transplanted tissues
that are not blood is much more complex
so in some sense this entire [ __ ]
rejection
donor complex is about
the simplicity of the antigens found on
red blood cells in the case of something
like liver
you're talking about a much more complex
set of antigens so that you need
a very good match at something called
the major histocompatibility complex
which is why you need to go through lots
of donors rather than there just being a
liver bank where you can go get one
that's a match for you
so now i know that there are
very different distributions of
probabilities for antigens for
purebred human populations what i don't
know is what the ancestral state was in
other words are some of these
blood types limited to some populations
and only
in recent times with human mixing have
these things spread between them
or were they always somewhat mixed but
the prevalences are different between
populations
i suspect a good analysis has been done
but i also don't know and the only one
the only sort of
map that i can pull up in my head right
now is that
native american populations meaning you
know the
the descendants of the original
baringians in both north america and
south america are more likely to be o
maybe and i don't know that there's
actually an rh factor
specificity there but i know it's o that
native americans are much less likely to
be
a b or a b yeah i would love to know
what the ancestral state was
it was purely oh at the point of the
beringians having descended into the
americas
or not yeah so but then the final part
of this question and then we'll
we'll end for today uh is why would o be
more resistant to cope at 19.
and especially let me just like add
something to the question
um for me like we don't know the answer
especially in light of it's not
that a b and a b are more susceptible to
covid but if i remember correctly it's a
that is specifically more susceptible
and then
b and a b blood types are kind of
neutral kind of in the middle
so it's not that like not having
antigens on your blood versus having
antigens
makes you susceptible or not it's it's a
very specific one that makes you
uh more susceptible versus having none
that makes you more resistant or less
susceptible yeah
um i don't know i think the thing the
first thing i would like to know in
order to answer the question
there is reason to think that red blood
cells probably do
not get infected that is to say even if
virus gets into red blood cells that it
cannot reproduce itself
but that is not dead certain so is that
because they're a nucleate
yeah so red blood cells in mammals have
no nucleus
but the coronaviruses do not integrate
into the nuclear genome and so it is
possible that they have
ribosomal components that would allow a
virus to
replicate itself even though it has no
nucleus and i would like to know whether
that happens or doesn't it's something
we should we should be able to look that
up
in which case it would almost certainly
have to do
with the difference in ability to enter
a red blood cell based on the antigens
on its surface
um uh but anyway i guess we'll have to
return to it after we know
yeah interesting question yep
and i think we're done all right so
um probably we'll be back on tuesday
yep uh join our patreons if you want
more you want access to the discord etc
uh
one more shout out to unity yep unity
2020 is going to have its first campfire
this week hopefully early based on
technical
considerations so come visit our
uh our twitter account um the hashtag
unity2020 will also likely get you that
announcement you can
sign up for our twitter accounts and uh
anyway we will get word out but please
join us for that campfire it should be
great
all right everyone thanks so much
[Music]
you